good morning tickets tuesday so to
understand the unfolding catastrophe in
ukraine i think it's really important to
have some historical and political
context first a quick snapshot of
ukraine it is the second largest country
in europe by area and at least as of
three weeks ago it was home to over 40
million people the national languages
are ukrainian which is the first
language of about two-thirds of
ukrainians and also russian which is the
first language of about 30 percent of
ukrainians russian is most commonly
spoken in the east and the south of the
country but gentle reminder that
language is not nationality ukrainian
history and cultural identity stretches
back a very long time but its history as
a nation-state really begins like a lot
of countries in world war one beginning
in 1917 ukraine was for a time an
independent nation called the ukrainian
people's republic which had this flag
and is seen as the forerunner of modern
ukraine which has this flag but like the
borders and even the existence of this
new country were always contested from
1917 to 1921 there was a war between the
ukrainian people's republic and the
bolsheviks who were just coming to power
in russia and in january of 1919 just
after the end of world war one the
bolsheviks invaded ukraine in full force
and eventually defeated the ukrainian
people's republic among other factions
wars are complicated and ukraine became
one of the soviet socialist republics of
the new union of soviet socialist
republics one of the generals who read
that bolshevik invasion of ukraine was
joseph stalin who cemented himself as
leader of the soviet union in 1929.
stalin wanted to crush any ukrainian
independence movements which for him
also meant discouraging ukrainian
language and cultural identity through a
variety of strategies many of them
horrific but we're going to focus today
on just two stalin policies that
continue to reverberate first the
holodomor as it is known in ukrainian in
1932 and 1933 millions of ukrainians
starved to death because of stalin's
agricultural policies wherein food was
taken from ukrainian homes and ukrainian
fields and sent elsewhere in the soviet
union especially to industrial centers
this period is sometimes known in
english as the terror famine to
emphasize that it was not the result of
blight or weather but of human choice so
to be clear the stalin regime knew what
it was doing these policies were
designed to punish ukrainian peasant
farmers who were seen to be resistant to
stalin's ideal of the soviet union it is
hard to overstate the horrors of the
holodomor perhaps one out of every eight
ukrainians died in a two-year period
another stalin-era policy that continues
to reverberate was forced deportation so
because stalin wanted to discourage
independence movements he forcibly moved
millions of people almost the entire
indigenous population of tatar people
were forcibly deported from their home
in the crimean peninsula many ukrainians
were forced to leave ukraine including
for prison camps in siberia and many
russian people were moved against their
will to various areas of the soviet
union as well including ukraine this had
a significant lasting effect on the
ethnic cultural and linguistic makeup of
a huge swath of eurasia from lithuania
to kazakhstan and it's worth noting that
many ukrainians today feel there are
parallels between that stalin-era policy
and what the putin regime is doing in
ukraine right now so putin has
repeatedly attacked these humanitarian
corridors people are trying to set up to
allow safe passage of civilians from
besieged cities into western ukraine or
other countries in europe but putin has
said i will guarantee your safety if you
come to russia basically saying you
can't stay safely in ukraine and you
can't go west but you can come to russia
which feels to a lot of people
fairly close to forced movement okay
let's move ahead to 1991 when the soviet
union is breaking up ukraine holds a
referendum to vote on whether to become
an independent nation and 92 percent of
people
vote for independence in every region of
ukraine a majority of people vote for
independence and as a result for the
last 30 years ukraine has been a
globally recognized independent nation
now it has not always gone great as i
explored in my previous video about
ukraine but also independence is
complicated in a global world especially
when the name of your country literally
means borderlands as ukraine does partly
due to cultural and historical
connections like millions of ukrainian
people have family in russia and partly
because of economic necessity ukraine
has had to maintain somewhat close ties
with russia while also trying to remain
you know a country economically ukraine
has been in a complicated relationship
with russia for the same reason the rest
of europe has been which is that russia
has a lot of oil and natural gas like
fossil fuels amounted to about 60
of russia's exports in 2019 that figure
is similar to like iran or the uae and
ukraine has been very reliant on imports
of russian energy sources not least
because at times those imports have been
heavily subsidized by russia to try to
curry favor and influence in ukraine but
here's where we arrive at the crux of
the matter for a country like ukraine it
is really difficult to have a good
relationship with russia because
russia's leader vladimir putin has long
maintained that ukraine should never
have existed i said earlier that for the
last 30 years ukraine has been a
globally recognized independent nation
but i realize now that's not quite true
because there is one place where ukraine
is not recognized as an independent
nation which is inside of vladimir
putin's head putin who has directly or
indirectly been the leader of russia for
over 20 years does not view ukraine as a
legitimate nation and that's not like an
accusation it's a statement of fact
putin has written repeatedly that he
believes ukraine is lacking in real
statehood and that ukraine was created
entirely by russia he thinks all
ukrainians should speak russian and
understand themselves to be part of what
has historically been russian land so
despite whatever the talking points are
in putin-friendly media putin himself
has repeatedly acknowledged exactly what
this war is about he does not believe
ukraine is a legitimate nation and he
believes quote the true sovereignty of
ukraine is possible only in partnership
with russia this is certainly not about
as some have claimed the protection of
ukrainians who speak russian as their
first language in fact in the first two
weeks of the war thousands of such
civilians have been killed by putin's
regime it is not about denotification of
ukraine a nation with a democratically
elected jewish president and while i
don't doubt that putin feels pressure
from the nato military alliance and i
don't want to minimize the complexities
there i simply don't think it makes
russia more safe to have russian
soldiers closer to nato missiles again
this is primarily about what putin has
said it is about he believes that when
the borders of ukraine were drawn russia
was robbed and he is seeking to rectify
that perceived injustice through
violence including the mass killing of
civilians and the destruction of
infrastructure that serves them i mean
just before the invasion putin addressed
ukraine by saying whether you like it or
not take it my darling which was widely
recognized to be a quote from a song
about sexually assaulting a corpse
vladimir putin told the world what he
was going to do
and now he is doing it i made a video
about ukraine eight years ago that ended
the arc of history is long let's hope it
bends toward peace
that was tragically naive i don't know
how this war will end only that it has
already caused tremendous suffering less
than three weeks into the putin regime's
invasion of ukraine millions of people
have been forced to flee their homes and
thousands have been killed including
many children i hope there is some way
forward other than more suffering but i
don't know what it is what i do know is
that no war will crush ukrainian
identity or language when i made a tick
talk about ukraine recently a young
person commented as a ukrainian i would
like to add one thing that i recently
understood myself
ukraine became ukraine by never giving
up on fighting for its freedom and
that's a good reminder that this war is
not about east versus west or whatever
it is about the right of ukraine and its
people to exist in freedom and
independence putin doesn't believe
ukraine has that right but he is
mistaken ukraine doesn't need to be a
russia-friendly country or a
europe-friendly country it should be
able to be its own country to make its
own choices secure in the knowledge that
its borders and sovereignty are
protected i believe that day will come
but i fear for every day until it does
hank i'll see you on friday